Qué implicaciones o consecuencias tiene
este acuerdo para las partes qué tanto
daño le habría hecho a Fox ir a juicio
Bueno aquí se hace bueno el dicho de ese
que dice que más vale un mal acuerdo que
un buen pleito no yo creo que Fox ha
valorado los riesgos de acudir un juicio
en el que podrían no salir muy bien
parada la imagen de la cadena de
televisión y bueno al fin y al cabo de
alguna manera totalmente es un
reconocimiento de que no se obró bien de
que no se obró con de acuerdo a la
verdad y con ética periodística y yo
creo que eso es lo más importante para
la empresa demandante para dominion así
que yo creo que las dos partes salen
como decía con un buen acuerdo y sin
haber corrido el riesgo de ese juicio de
ese pleito público que hubiera sido
realmente Una vergüenza probablemente
para Fox no bueno dentro de Estados
Unidos la cadena tiene un público
bastante definido de alguna manera
reconocer que min tieron porque pues
esto fue parte del acuerdo les genera
una verdadera afectación
yo creo que para una parte del público
para esa parte de fieles a la que tú
comentas no porque realmente incluso con
todo esto Habrá gente todavía convencida
de que realmente hubo fraude con las
máquinas de votación hay un sector de la
población que es inconvencible Aunque la
realidad le demuestre lo contrario Pero
hay otro gran hay otro gran núcleo de
gente que está más en el centro a lo
mejor Incluso en la línea ideológica de
Fox centro derecha derecha pero que sí
que tiene una capacidad de análisis
mayor y que y que bueno que sí podría
castigar este tipo de comportamientos al
final los medios competimos unos con
otros y la credibilidad y la veracidad
es muy importante aparte de que es muy
importante digamos que distinguir entre
lo que es información y lo que es
opinión en este caso ni siquiera se
puede poner bajo el paraguas de la
opinión porque esto no no es cierto no
no se demostró que no era cierto que las
máquinas de votación hubieran estado
trucadas o que hubieran favorecido
alguna manera el partido demócrata
y justamente le pregunto se puede hablar
de decepción entre los sectores
demócratas tras este acuerdo porque
muchos querían que Fox fuera juzgado por
lo que califican como un ataque a la
democracia
por supuesto No yo creo que la que los
demócratas la izquierda estadounidense
quería escarnio público para Fox que al
fin y al cabo con todos sus virtudes
esos defectos es una cadena conservadora
que siempre está atacando las posiciones
demócratas e izquierdistas entonces
Bueno en ese sentido se ha evitado ese
ese juicio público que hubiera sido
seguido por medios de Estados Unidos y
de todo el mundo y que hubiera sacado
muchas como decía antes muchas
vergüenzas de estos tres presentadores
que Que bueno que al fin y al cabo
inventaron no sabemos al final si a
sabiendas o no historias sobre sobre las
máquinas de votación de aquellas
elecciones